L
GAME OF CAT AND MOUSE BETWEEN
THE AGENTS AND THE MIGRANTS.
DUE SOUTH OF TUCSON, ARIZONA,
ONE OF THE MOST TREACHEROUS
STRETCHES OF THE U.S./MEXICO
BORDER.
262 MILES OF HOT, DRY, OFTEN
MOUNTAINOUS TERRAIN.
AND YET, MORE AND MORE MIGRANTS
ARE STILL COMING NORTH.
ENCOUNTERS IN THIS SECTOR ARE UP
MORE THAN 150% FROM LAST YEAR.
DETECTIONS BY THE BORDER
PATROL'S DRONES MONITORING THE
AREA FROM UP HIGH HAVE TRIPLED.
AND MIGRANTS AND SMUGGLERS ARE
USING NEW MILITARY-STYLE TACTICS
TO AVOID CAPTURE.
WE JOINED AGENTS FROM THE U.S.
BORDER PATROL TUCSON SECTOR ON
OPERATIONS TRACKING AND
APPREHENDING MIGRANTS FROM
MEXICO, CENTRAL AND SOUTH
AMERICA.
IT IS A CHALLENGING, HIGHLY
TECHNICAL AND SOMETIMES
DANGEROUS EFFORT.
ENCOMPASSING HELICOPTER PATROLS,
UNMANNED AERIAL SURVEILLANCE AND
BORDER PATROL AGENTS ON FOOT.
ATVs AND HORSEBACK.
OUR CHOPPER PILOTED BY AGENT
ALEXIS CLARK, GETS A RADIO ALERT
OF MIGRANTS SPOTTED ATTEMPTING
TO CROSS A ROCKY RIDGELINE
SEVERAL THOUSAND FEET HIGH.
ON FOOT, AGENTS TRACK THE GROUP
SEARCHING FOR SIGNS OF DISTURBED
GROUND.
IN THE SKY, OUR PILOT CIRCLES
THE AREA TO SPOT THEM FROM
ABOVE.
>> A GROUP OF TWO UNDER A TREE
FROM THE AIR IS TOUGH.
SO, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO LOOK
FOR THAT VARIATION IN CLOTHING,
A FOOT STICKING OUT.
SOME MOVEMENT.
JUST A GOOD EYE FROM AN AIR CREW
JUST SPOT SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T
LOOK RIGHT.
>> Reporter: WITHIN MINUTES,
SUCCESS.
AGENTS DISCOVER A GROUP OF FIVE
MEN HIDING UNDER A TREE AND
DETAIN THEM.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES IN
PATROLLING THIS PART OF THE
BORDER IS MIGRANTS COMING HERE,
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE CAUGHT.
THEY'RE NOT GIVING THEMSELVES UP
TO GET INTO THE LEGAL SYSTEM IN
THE U.S.
THEY'RE TRYING TO CROSS ON THEIR
OWN, AVOID BORDER PATROL ALONG
THE WAY.
SO A LOT OF TIMES WHEN THEY'RE
SPOTTED, THEY DON'T GIVE
THEMSELVES UP.
THEY RUN AND THAT MAKES THE JOB
OF BORDER PATROL AGENTS THAT
MUCH TOUGHER.
THESE ARE NOT FAMILIES AND
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN.
BORDER PATROL SAYS 85% WHO CROSS
HERE ARE SINGLE ADULTS, SOME
WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS.
THE CROSSINGS NOW RESEMBLE
MILITARY OPERATIONS.
MIGRANTS WEAR CAMOUFLAGE.
BOOTS MADE FROM CARPET TO
OBSCURE THEIR FOOTSTEPS AND
CRUCIALLY COME ACROSS IN
MULTIPLE SMALL GROUPS DROPPED
ALONG THE BORDER AND TOLD TO
ENTER AT DIFFERENT TIMES TO
OUTWITH AND OVERWHELM THE BORDER
PATROL.
>> WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
SWARMING.
SO INSTEAD OF IN YEARS GONE BY
WHERE WE'D HAVE A GROUP OF 20,
GROUP OF 30 CROSSING THE BORDER.
CURRENTLY TWO GROUPS OR TEN
GROUPS OF TWO.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THEY
SPLIT UP, CROSS THE BORDER AND
IT TAKES TWO AGENTS OR ONE AGENT
TO ADDRESS EACH ONE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUAL GROUPS.
SO WE BECOME TASK SATURATED.
>> Reporter: WHY THE SURGE NOW?
MANY MIGRANTS BELIEVE, FALSELY,
THAT U.S. LAW CHANGED WITH THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION.
>> THE LAWS FOR IMMIGRATION HAVE
NOT CHANGED SO OUR JOB HAS NOT
CHANGED.
SO WE ARE STILL ENFORCING THE
SAME LAWS WE'VE BEEN ENFORCING
FOR MANY YEARS.
>> Reporter: CONSTRUCTION OF NEW
BORDER WALL, INCLUDING THE 137
MILES BUILT IN THIS SECTOR HAS
BEEN HALTED.
LEAVING WIDE GAPS LIKE THIS ONE.
THIS IS PART OF THE NEW BORDER
WALL.
30 FEET HIGH MADE OUT OF STEEL.
THIS IS THE KIND OF BARRIER IT
REPLACED IN A LOT OF SECTIONS OF
THE BORDER HERE.
SOMETHING ABOUT WAIST HIGH MEANT
TO STOP CARS, NOT PEOPLE.
EASY TO GET RIGHT UNDER IT.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENED IN SECTIONS
LIKE THIS THAT ARE INCOMPLETE IS
THEY BECOME NEW TRANSIT POINTS.
YOU CAN TELL THAT BECAUSE THE
BARBED WIRE HERE BENT UP FROM
THE BOTTOM SO YOU CAN CRAWL
UNDER IT.
LOTS OF FOOTPRINTS SHOWING LOTS
OF FOOT TRAFFIC.
SMUGGLERS HAVE BEEN BUILT A ROAD
HERE FOR BETTER ACCESS TO THIS
ENTRY POINT MAKING IT EVEN
EASIER TO CROSS.
SO THE BULK OF THE WORK REMAINS
WITH AGENTS MAKING CAPTURE
OPERATIONS LIKE THIS ONE THE
BORDER PATROL'S PRIMARY MISSION.
>> WALKING TOWARD THE WEST.
>> THREE CONFIRMED ON THE
IMAGES.
>> Reporter: UNDER WAY, 24 HOURS
A DAY, 7 DAYS A WEEK.
NO BREAK FOR WEATHER OR
NIGHTFALL.
>> LOOK AT ALL THIS.
>> Reporter: WE FOLLOWED AGENTS
ON A GROUND PATROL AFTER
PRESSURE SENSORS AND CAMERAS ON
A FREQUENTLY USED TRAIL DETECTED
MULTIPLE MIGRANTS.
IT'S A LONG, EXHAUSTING SEARCH.
TEMPERATURES NEAR 100 DEGREES.
SMUGGLERS FAMILIAR WITH HOW TO
USE THE TERRAIN TO AVOID
DETECTION.
>> I'M WALKING AROUND HERE.
I DON'T SEE HOW THEY FOLLOW THE
SIGNS.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE OF THE
CARPET BOOTIES THEY WEAR.
>> IT TAKES A LOT OF SKILL FROM
BORDER PATROL AGENTS TO BE ABLE
TO MASTER THAT AND IT TAKES
HOURS SOMETIMES.
WE CAN TRACK FOR HOURS BUT
HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO MAKE
THIS APPREHENSION.
>> Reporter: THIS TIME, AGENT
LOSE THE TRAIL AND AIR ASSETS
MOVE ON TO ANOTHER POTENTIAL
SITE.
WE GET WORD THAT AGENTS MAY HAVE
SPOTTED ANOTHER GROUP OF
MIGRANTS CLOSER TO THE BORDER.
>> AT YOUR 10:00.
THEY'RE HEADED WEST.
>> Reporter: THIS GROUP IS
PROVING EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO
FIND.
TAKING REFUGE IN A DRY RIVERBED
TO PROVIDE COVER OF TREES AND
VEGETATION.
THIS FAMILIAR TACTIC TURNS THE
AGENTS ONCE AGAIN INTO TRACKERS.
SEARCHING SAND AND GRAVEL FOR
FOOTPRINTS.
ON SEARCHES LIKE THIS ONE, THEY
HAVE SOME PARTICULARLY HELPFUL
PARTNERS.
A BELGIAN SHEPHERD, ONE MEMBER
OF THE CANINE UNIT AND AGENTS
MOUNTED ON HORSEBACK, FAST AND
DURABLE IN THE MOUNTAINS.
AFTER NEARLY AN HOUR IN THE AIR,
ASCENDING AND DESCENDING THE
RIDGELINE AT AS LOW AS 20 FEET
ALTITUDE AND HOURS OF
PAINSTAKING SEARCHING BY AGENTS
ON THE GROUND --
THEY FIND THEIR TARGET.
SEVEN MEN IN TELL-TALE
CAMOUFLAGE.
THIS IS THE NEW REALITY, NOT
ONE, BUT TWO SURGES ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
IN TEXAS, FAMILIES AND CHILDREN
OFTEN TURNING THEMSELVES IN, AND
HERE IN ARIZONA, SINGLE ADULTS
DIRECTED L